well it's great to see you this morning
I'm glad you braved it out on a Saturday
morning a weekend to come enjoy open
source software its finest the PI data
conference series is a phenomenal
worldwide movement it's been a real
treat to watch you and your colleagues
around the world create this conference
series it was impressive to me with the
demand for this effort when we started
the very first one in 2012 we were
recognizing the interest in data science
and the fact that everybody was using
Python and nobody was really talking
about it and so we created this
conference series really bring people
together and it just exploded it was
always based on the principle of
community organization so there is a
foundational group at none focus that
helps support and provide some
consistency for these conferences but
they don't happen without your support
and without your organizational effort
so whenever I look at on the webpage and
I see 14 conferences around the world I
don't know what the exact number is this
year but it's something big I'm just
really impressed by the momentum of all
of you open source really is a fantastic
phenomenon and I thought I'd talk today
a little about my story with open source
and it goes back ways I've been doing
this for a while and trying to figure
out how to make it work with business
for a while and so I thought I'd just
share some of my experiences today it's
kind of a little more personal of a talk
some may have seen parts of this if you
watch my PI did a New York City talk I
it'll be basically roughly the same with
this awesome I'm sure a few iterations
but it is a little exposing to me kind
of I tend to shy away from getting to
into the details of things I've
experienced and what I've done and I'll
probably go into some more details here
and hopefully some will be useful to you
and you and help you in your journey to
make your life and your earning
potential and your ability to contribute
to the world consistent with your
ability contribute to open source which
is really the the goal I've had for
twenty years
as I'll explain this timeline kind of
helps you orient to kind of the the some
of the things we'll be talking about on
the top is kind of my journey I started
in Python at open source in 1998 1999
1988 while I was at the Mayo Clinic I
really got started in my career to be a
scene we call it a biomedical engineer
MRI and ultrasounds what I studied and
then kind of through the course of time
I've ended up doing more and more
software still with a passion for
scientific discovery and scientific
exploration and I've been happy to
realize that actually business is not
that different from science in terms of
trying to discover what the world needs
discovering what people want and what
will pay for and so there's a lot of
similarities to my experiences in
science that have shown up in business
as well and below is this explosion of
open source ecosystem that's that's
emerged many people are surprised to
learn that Syfy came out so much earlier
than numpy but it's because there was an
array object that came before numeric
was actually already available when I
came to Python and that's the reason I
came to Python but because the work that
people had done to create numeric and
then numpy we'll talk about its story so
for me it started with Syfy and my goal
was just help people connect to these
wonderful Fortran libraries and give you
more utilities the ability to do
ordinary differential equations solving
integration special function computation
just all the kinds of things you want to
be able to do very quickly at a high
level in Python that you couldn't do in
2001 of course any of these large
projects that exist they do start with a
few people but they don't survive and
they don't grow unless a lot of people
get involved and that's true for every
project I've been a part of that has
succeeded Syfy certainly started in 1998
with some of the work I did and then in
2001 we put it together to Syfy with
some of my colleagues Piero and Eric and
then today is sustained by 670
contributors of course there's a
power-law it's about 5 or 10 maybe 10 15
significant contributors then a whole
lot of other people helping to make it
work my open source addiction that
started with Syfy continued with numpy
while I was a professor and that now is
supported by a very large community of
708 contributors well and a growing
number of core developers it's it's
astonishing to me actually just how
successful numpy has been compared to
what I imagined I knew I wanted to bring
communities together and allow an equal
develop but it's been really humbling
and astonishing to see just how much can
it be accomplished when people work
together in a distributed fashion and
that's kind of what I want to talk about
today is how do people work together and
distributed fashion in a way that's
consistent we still haven't solved the
problem here yet though I mean I look
back and I'm enthused by the success of
the users of numpy insight pie and of
course the heartfelt and dedicated
effort of many of the contributors
Charles Harris has been Ralph gomers
Polyvore Tannen many many people who
have essentially given all kinds of time
to make sure these packages stay
consistent but many of most of them are
funded almost almost none of them are
funded and so in a day when Google and
Facebook and Microsoft and Amazon are
funding dozens and dozens of Engineers
to work in this space and companies like
JPMorgan and Capital One and Bank of
America and large investment banks fund
thousands of engineers who work with
these tools the fact that there's only a
couple of people funded full-time to
work and maintain these tools yeah
there's a problem here right it's a
problem that I knew about when I started
but as soon as some I've been trying to
figure out a fix the whole time but it
is a problem there's no funding you know
is it people that create this don't have
funding they're just kind of trying to
figure out what they do everyone use
their stuff but there's no way to
continue working on it without some kind
of connected support GPU the support
could have been added a ton PI five
years ago six years ago easily but it
wasn't so instead we have kind of other
array libraries showing up to probably
that GPU support sci-fi took 17 years to
hit 1.0 right not because people are
lazy because they didn't have jobs they
were just working pull in their nights
and weekends and that that's fine when
you're talking about a hobbyist project
but once project start clean use this
scale it doesn't work anymore it just
doesn't work anymore and so numpy could
already be a 2.0 but not without
full-time guidance and leadership and
projects to support it so that's a real
problem and num focus is at the
forefront of trying to help fix this
problem and there are other approaches
as well it's August apart that's the
problem of OS sustainability open-source
sustainability open source software
sustainability
and what happens this developers get
burned out I guess my voice being
harassed me right now has a extra effect
doesn't it that wasn't intentional or
help heard out we're miserable no it's
absurd but it is true that people
sometimes sacrifice and I don't
recommend this but in fact I recommend
the opposite one of the reasons I've
been able to sustain so long and open
source activities because I haven't the
work life harmony is important having
other things outside of your life that
you care about is important but but it's
easy it burned out and I've seen this
and I've experienced some of those
emotions myself developers from the
unbalance lives there's a lot of job
opportunities just living off the
generosity of you I'm not here to make
you feel guilty I'm here to talk about
how do we fix this because ultimately
it's aligned incentives to make it work
nobody's doing this intentionally
nobody's trying to hurt anybody we're
always using stuff that we can use and
making our local decisions so how do we
fix it and that's kind of what I've been
interested for a long time this is a
very personal journey for me and as I've
explained I've been eyes wide open to
this for 20 years I've known about the
problems that can exist with tragedy
Commons with common utilities and have a
very interested in it I spoke earlier
about my addiction to open source and
it's kind of true I've really got a
passion for contributed open source I
love the community building I love the
fact that people could share ideas
across the world instantly once they're
created so I love participating MSS but
I have to do a sustainably so I don't
have to really think theoretically about
this I just have to look at my kids and
the fact that they need more and more
funding than their peers now they're
going on college age and and it's it
seems to get more expensive every year
so I have to do it sustainably and I
want to do that in a way that other
people can as well so of course many
people know about that strategy in the
Commons
we're at a financial institution this is
probably people here who explain this
much better than I could but the idea is
that if you have a common resource where
everybody can just take it it's really
becomes over grazing and overuse is a
known problem it's called a negative
externality of market forces it's been
written about widely it's very
understood there's a lot of solutions
that have emerged I think there's a lot
of solutions that can still emerge you
look throughout biology look throughout
nature and nature solves this problem
lots of ways - there's all kinds of
natural tragedies of common situations
that occur in ecosystems and lots of
solutions our eyes actually there isn't
just one but the problem is real and if
you know these users keep using the
Commons and don't contribute back then
eventually it it doesn't work so you
know one analogy if the grass is
open-source developers and the sheep are
the users of open-source we're just
using it and then not really helping to
maintain it not sponsoring new ones not
encouraging new ones not not providing
for the support of the of the of the
open-source developers then pretty soon
you have these wilted and dead
open-source developers who are kind of
worn out and then in addition I think
you you then probably the biggest
problem is that you don't have examples
that show how working an open-source can
be prosperous now we have a couple
obviously Red Hat had a great big exit
IBM we've had other open source
companies get an exit and I think
they're their approximate answers I
think they're they're their steps in the
right direction and there's many other
folks that are making steps in the right
direction but it is a real issue and I
think it's actually pretty deep I don't
think our education or political system
is really helping a lot of the
fundamentals of profit money how free
markets coordinate the scarce resources
is widely misunderstood a lot of people
there are people who would sort of they
look as scans to the fact that there are
some people making money in open source
and they get nervous about that you know
it's either all free or it's like
socialism capitalism that's the only two
options you've got right which is just I
just agree with that I think that's the
wrong framing for the problem I think
the right framing starts with
recognizing that profit and money are
principles of human cooperation at scale
we all understand computing a scale do
we think about human cooperation at
scale and how does that accomplished how
do you actually coordinate the resources
of millions of people without having a
single point of control how do you do
that I don't know there's perfect but we
can observe that profit profit motive
sort of am I making sense of the world
am i doing something with my resources
that other people are you are liking so
that I'm making a profit is it working
and money is that coordinating tool is
works it's known to work for thousands
of years how do I else do you coordinate
the behavior of millions of people
across
nations across political spectrums
across belief systems I don't know of
any other system that works as well so
we need much better dialogue of course
it's not perfect didn't say it was it is
a nothing is perfect and if you're
open-source you recognize that - for
years I look at numpy and I see all the
warts and so I'm proud of the
accomplishments but I'm also embarrassed
sometimes I look and say who's the idiot
that wrote this stuff because it should
be much better and that happens all the
time and it's like I think most things
are like that it's not one or the other
it's a mix and we have to have better
dialogue it's not about capitalism or
socialism it's about connecting aligned
incentives and helping people who are in
open-source continue to be able to work
in open-source my perspective business
and open-source are about people they're
really the same thing
they're about competing to cooperate
with each other they're about voluntary
connections and that's the power to me
those are the powerful dynamics that I'm
looking for in life looking for
situations where you can be voluntary
engaged with folks
nobody's coerced into that relationship
they can step away from it what's not
working for them anymore
then what I see throughout my life and
open-source and business is a very same
thing and I love helping people and so I
love both of these scenarios and both
these environments I've been trying to
figure out how to connect these two in a
deep way give a little background as how
do i came to some of these views so i
started as a grad student 1997 1989 at
the Mayo Clinic and I encountered Linux
I started install Linux I went oh this
is great I could write C code I got to
read other people's code I loved it of
course Richard Stallman had a lot of
great essays about free software and the
power of ideas when freely shared and I
loved reading his literature I read
everything he had most everything he
wrote then I came across something he
wrote that I realized I couldn't I
couldn't agree with he said I therefore
urge you to do as I have done and have
no children
so his little too late for me I already
had three so I couldn't send them back
and they were they were darling actually
I loved them and they and and they're
amazing and I'm really grateful I've had
that had those kids and I would not urge
you some people won't some people can I
mean it's an orthogonal question you
know and I don't think they should be
related so I did read Eric Raymond I
think he had some really good things to
say about the power of connecting you
know many eyeballs debugging it sort of
got me excited
I then experience the power of open
source by grabbing and learning UNIX by
building a mini cluster with a bunch of
max it's the Maverick ability to grab
code and read it and understand it
I could read the Python code base learn
from the great the the great developers
that are there and me as a scientist who
knew enough about C and programming to
be dangerous but never having really
taken computer science I could really
rapidly understand more and more by
reading the code so it was a great great
environment for a learning of course
questions I had led to more questions
and that's sort of the continuation of
if you read zen an art or more of
motorcycle maintenance that's kind of
its main premise is that questions
always lead to more questions there's
really never answers there are answers
but there's more questions so it's good
news actually because answering
questions gives a little endorphin kick
and it's neurobiological actually so one
you know to be addicted to getting
questions answered that's kind of part
of the addiction open source you're
addicted to that endorphin kick of
actually having doing something for
people having a related finding out an
answer to something it's it's a
wonderful thing and one of the good
kinds of addictions that we can have in
our life so it led to questions like how
do I work on open source software while
still providing for my family I was a
young graduate student working on sci-fi
and my wife thought I was supposed to be
finishing grad school we were making
eighteen thousand dollars a year I had
three kids don't ask me how he did that
probably cuz was Minnesota and not
Boston Cambridge but she was thinking I
was gonna finish soon and I kind of
delayed it by a year because of all of
1999 I took writing type I basically so
I had that question I knew I couldn't do
that forever so how do I do this and
still and how do others do this so that
led me to understand how two economies
work how do you make people better off
generally so I just did my own personal
study on that and tried to find all the
information I could that led me to
Austin account economics I'm not gonna
give you a lecture in Austin economics
I'm going to it's a it's not one group
of thought there's a bunch of writers
some of them brilliant others a little
bit tedious a little bit hard to
understand but there's some really good
thought that's going on out there but a
lot of smart people trying to grapple
with this problem as well and I like the
first principles I like the concepts
they emerged some of the key takeaways I
took from my study of some of these
writers like Frederick Hayek and Ludwig
lemma says a sous work that they sought
though I like that
the coordinating power of money and
profits just the ability to help humans
cooperate his scale that was a powerful
idea that I hadn't heard of anywhere
else it sort of been absent from
education I think it's absent for a lot
of other people's education and it
causes us to have bad dialogue because
we have to recognize that power I'm
gonna replace it with something else got
to replace it with what we got it we got
to come to the table knowing what's
working and what's there I also learned
that entrepreneurs are critical you need
people experimenting in the market
trying to figure out what people want
and trying to it's trying stuff out they
need a lot of them and you just support
them you help them when they fail
ultimately and encourage that that
process I really wasn't
I wasn't born an entrepreneur I would
say I was educated into it I sort of saw
the light as the need for it and said I
better try to do that and so I've been
working at that you know for the past 12
15 years
I also learned about the structure of
capital structure of capital it's not
just one big pool there's the pool is
tied up into all kinds of inventory into
infrastructure and that and how its
structured matters and leads to
challenges and you know structure of
capital is actually part of an a bigger
question is the structure relationships
and you start looking at open source
communities the structure those
communities starts to matter and who
people aren't who they were connected to
starts to matter so more takeaways
voluntary trade requires win-win
situations that's in order for someone
to trade with you they have to agree and
you have to agree so you both have to
see it as valuable assuming there's our
any course of elements around forcing
the conversation which still happens I'm
not naive to that but I loved I found
that I love finding win-win situations
it's actually really fun trying to
figure out hey we both benefit this is
great and finding those is kind of the
essence of entrepreneurship at scale a
lot of people searching for those
win-win situations
that's entrepreneurs by a trial and
error basically that's how we make
economic progress we don't make economic
progress without that energy so
societies that encourage that get more
of it and then get more business growth
it's really not about big companies
little little people
it's about lots of entrepreneurs
and sort of encouraging those
entrepreneurs yes externalities and
traps to occur you can be announcer more
that entrepreneur that effectively traps
people in their addictions not
supportive of that you can be an
entrepreneur that sort of games the
system there are people that do that not
a big fan of that there definitely
things you can do that aren't that I
would say are not good so I think good
is bigger than this these are just sort
of functions they're like little
subroutines it could be applied why you
should apply them and when it's a bigger
question and something that can be
debated and should be I don't have all
the answers nobody else does either but
ideas an attitude does matter how people
how you think about your situation
totally affects what you're gonna do
about it
many people get trapped before they get
started they're different they're
different people with risk profiles I
think a risk aversion is one obviously
one of the big heart things about
entrepreneurship is it takes some risk
I was asked in India when I gave a talk
some he says when should you start a
business and the Indians are great
they're wonderful people a lot of risk
aversion there a lot of I think there's
a lot of family dynamics that cause
people not to you know they don't wanna
look bad because you you start a company
you start anything and it might not go
well there's a lot of things out of your
control there are definitely things you
can control but a whole lot of things
you can't and so the ideas you have the
risk aversion you have can definitely
matter so that that was kind of the
fabric the framework I kind of learned
those principles while I was getting my
PhD and then I ended up in his Gratton
school teaching I went back to my alma
mater and taught at a university
professor and I kind of realized that I
learned all this wonderful stuff about
business and the world and
entrepreneurship and it really wasn't
matching with a career in academia so I
sometimes say I sacrificed tenure to
write numpy but that is only half of the
story I knew I really wasn't meant for
academia as soon as I realized that I
had this desire to connect communities
and open source and to connect
businesses and to kind of help figure
out some way to add-ins in in some way
if possible to that story of making a
cent of businesses that worked can spin
that ibly with open-source communities
under underneath it all is this powerful
idea that when you share it when you
create something and share it with the
world everybody can use it the group can
use it the world can use it it has been
absolutely amazing
be able to travel the world and notice
there are people poor people rich people
doesn't matter people with all kinds of
you have all of a sudden to lift because
they can use software that otherwise
they wouldn't have got their hands on
and they could not only just use it they
can contribute to it they can take the
next step to become contributors to
actually grow in their ecosystems
whether it's South America or India or
even Africa so excited there's a PyCon
africa emerging not just in south africa
where there's been infrastructure for a
while but in ghana in ethiopia some of
these areas people can get become
contributors and meaningful contributors
to the community that's a powerful idea
and something I'm super excited about so
all that effort kind of led to this
enormous sort of ecosystem which is only
happen because of other individuals like
it's it's humbling to be a part of it
but I totally recognize it's the
strength and the power of everybody else
that made this happen
that's the power of groups as I said
I've been all that learning happened 20
years ago right and I knew when I was
writing Saipan numpy I kind of not sure
how this is gonna work I'm not really
sure I'm trying to figure it out I'm not
sure so effectively starting right after
I left academia in academia was part of
it it was for support open-source but
having a research lab having people that
could work on it and and funding funding
professors funding graduate students so
I knew theoretically about the
potentials of negative externalities I
need the problem the tragedies of
Commons I knew that this may happen
I knew that business solutions would
need to be found but I jumped into it I
believe in people I believe in the
cording and power of shared ideas I
believe solutions can be found that
enable us to build sustainably on the
power of shared code share data shared
ideas
stay tuned for 2019 have actually had
some interesting epiphanies over that
over the past few weeks they're not
developed enough for me to share with
you right now but I'm very excited about
some of the things we're gonna be doing
in 2019 that I think can meaningfully
affect this over the next five years
they're meaningful but they're
mountainous right they're not simple
hacks they're actually things that could
that will take a while to emerge but
they're worth pursuing so I'm excited
about that as a someone to pursue for
the next five to ten years so thought
I'd tell you about little early efforts
I did and kind of some of the experience
I had and see if that can help resonate
with you or you can learn from
so when I was at BYU teaching it's a
professor Brigham Young University in
the electrical engineering department I
was continuing work on Syfy it's beamed
before I started the numpy effort which
I started as a professor there and so I
would have hired graduate students and
they'd work on things like sci-fi sparse
and the iterative algorithms and in the
iterative sci-fi interact and sci-fi
special and I try to figure out to fund
them and knowing what I knew about
entrepreneurship and wanting to kind of
participate in the in the world of
shared ideas in the world of voluntary
exchange I wanted to build a research
lab on the basis of individual
individual contributions so I that's a
difficult undertaking by the way that's
sort of how I learned firsthand about
the what it takes to get donors how
difficult that can be some of the
challenges associated with it
I made the DVD I you know one of the
principles is hey you can give somebody
something and then they might get back
to you so I made a DVD my wife's a
beautiful singer we made a recording and
put a DVD out and I gave that to about a
thousand people and just asked for
donations to my lab right and I got
about five five thousand bucks right
from that campaign right it was it was
not huge but it was meaningful it was
helpful and so that kind of you know was
one experience then I wrote when I wrote
numpy kind of thinking about man how I'm
gonna fund this how I'm gonna help it
well maybe I could write a book and that
was a known way to kind of raise money
as you write document do you write a
book you write a book you sell and then
some monies raised from the book and it
was at the time you know self-publishing
you could self-published I'm not
recommending you always self-published I
think the publishers have a great value
add that they provide at the time I
really don't want to deal with that I
wanted to I was spending too much time
on the software so I published it myself
and I kind of invented this new concept
called the market determined copyright
time it really is going back to the
principle of copyright and patents
originally their whole idea was for a
for a short period of time they're gonna
allow the government to basically force
everybody not to copy sort of allow the
government to force people not to do
something comes naturally which is just
copy what you have but only for a
limited time right that was all
principle like for a period of time will
allow that to try to encourage them to
make money off of that idea now
that's kind of way out of control is
originally 14 years with an extension
now it's crazy
patents I think they're they're
reasonable but their challenges it's
different things are need to be have
different patents and not everything
should be patented this being patented
little s I liked the idea so I said hey
we'll do it this way I need $250,000
right for the funding of numpy right so
I'm going to release this as soon as I
make that much money off of the book but
that was the idea so I put it out there
instead of be free or four years if I
can't do it in four years and it's not
worth it so that was kind of the
principle and you know it worked to a
degree actually had a pretty good
response 3,000 people about the book
raised about $90,000 half of that
two-thirds of that went to graduate
student who the one graduate student I
had from China who was finishing his
ph.d özil the fund him because of that
and then the rest covered a summer for
me and then but after six months you
pretty much about two years in I got a
job in the industry at a company called
n thon so I made the material public
domain because it was sort of not it
made more sense for what I was doing
then just to make the material free and
then also it became the foundation of
the Sci Fi documentation project so I
don't know that that's the right answer
obviously I don't think any of these
things are the right answer they're
really just explorations that I'm
teaching I'm sharing with you so you can
help me figure out better answers and
also figure them out for yourself
so then I went to end thought and
thought was the first consulting job I
took I went to a company in Austin Texas
it was the same founded by the same
individual who helped me create a sci-fi
to begin with and in 2001 so I joined
them 2008 2007 and I was joining so I
could grow numpy in sci-fi that's what I
was passionate about I wanted to go
there figure out a way to fund that by
doing consulting work and then we could
fund I'm fine site by together and so it
turned out the sci-fi numpy work was
nights and weekends not just for me but
for a few other people that join kind of
the same reason we did manage to grow a
great conference series in Syfy
conference that benefited both the
community and was a marketing benefit to
the company so it was a reason it was a
good trade couldn't really connect much
contract work directly we weren't
successful at doing that
the contract work that was obtained was
primarily around the untaught tool suite
so even though it is true you can build
an open-source company off you can build
a kind of consulting company off of
open-source that's one way to do and
that was actually doing it off of the
untaught tool suite of this open-source
base not none by side by really so that
was one of the challenges there are
challenges with the real with the
consulting model there really isn't a
real incentive to produce documentation
it's sort of yeah it's only because you
want it and you want users but writing
good documentation kind of means you're
writing you're providing help to people
to compete with you there's not a real
incentive to grow a community of country
contributors they end up becoming
competitors potentially so there's some
challenges that way you kind of to do it
you have to believe fundamentally that
by growing the ecosystem you're growing
the pie and I think ultimately that can
work because I guess a consulting
company recognize you're not gonna say
there's no one consulting company that
could support the entire sci-fi
ecosystem at this point there isn't it's
too many is too diverse and so you
effectively can grow the pie and then
how you will grow in the same time lots
of other people will grow too so I think
you can get around that and this idea
still can't hold merit but you do have
to remember not to make the local
decision to not produce documentation or
not train people for fear you know don't
make a decision out of fear make a
decision out of faith that the world
that the markets growing that's my
approach my recommended approach it can
be difficult to get time to work on open
source because when you contract with
somebody they want their project done
and so you have to you have to work with
them and earlier it was harder it's
getting easier now but companies were
not helping themselves by wanting to own
all that all the IP hey your work for
hires everything you do is mine that's
the nap that's the standard contract
language the challenge is okay do you
really want to maintain your own forked
numpy you really want to maintain your
own fork or sci-fi or any other
open-source project just surely what we
make changes to the code that's
open-source we should move that back to
open-source fortunately today and
companies are much more enlightened and
most of them will agree with that and
it's pretty straightforward but you do
have to fight with their lawyers
sometimes the lawyer still sometimes
don't understand that and get a little
bit well this way it's always been done
well you're wrong should be done
differently and not sure on from my
perspective you're wrong for your
company your client your clients worse
off
maintain a fork of an open-source
project but it can be a good way so
consulting you know it's it's it's it's
got a place it's got a place in it many
people do it this way and there are many
examples of people doing services around
open-source projects of course it didn't
thought I also learned how to fundraise
I learned some kind of clever approaches
perhaps they're not really that clever
but coaches that aren't as well known to
use 401ks to fund other people's
companies to fund your own company's
little trick here if you're interested
in any of this
they'll come talk to me I can guide you
can give you somebody ideas about how to
map how this works and how you can
basically tap in to the capital that's
out there you know a lot of people love
you'll have access to this kind of
capital and you can use it to create
organizations and companies that support
open-source only didn't work out for me
and thought and I needed to leave that
kind of ROS other concerns about
open-source and business which is when
if your open-source company is too tied
to if it's a company and tied to
open-source what happens if the company
divorces if the people split and that's
certainly Eric and I weren't the first
to this ever happen to it happens all
the time and it happens quite regularly
so what does that mean what does that
mean for sci-fi sci-fi is that nomming
the to the kids have to choose between
me and Eric right it's maybe a bad
analogy but it kind of felt that way
it's like I didn't wanted people to bid
didn't matter and then people don't care
all the people of all Masai if I did not
care they could care less right they
just want to make sure the conference is
working in the libraries work so I
didn't want community participants have
to choose between us it's one of the
reasons when I started out of Conda
which is the second was a company I
founded it when I left and thought also
created none focus it was really
important to me that we create and I'm
focus is a place to host open source
there was community led so that it was
kind of a board that was decided by the
community and grown by the community now
now it's really hard to do to build one
company and here we were building two
organizations at once and it was hard
definitely hard there's a lot of people
were confused a little bit they're
saying wait isn't unfocused Travis's
little thing is it sort of some some
tricks to get us to contribute and then
somehow he's gonna take it and there
were lots of people with their naysayers
for sure after a couple of years people
could see no this is real this is
actually a real community centric
organization and he's got his company
this is other thing
and they're separated but they each have
a different role to play anaconda the
goal was to build a product based
company that would drive revenue that
could be reinvested back in open source
all right that was the goal of anaconda
and still is it still is my goal a
friend of conda's PI data gnome focus
was meant to be an organization led by
the community that could go where the
community wanted it to go effectively so
non focus and community-centric
organizations I think are critical to
the future and have been critical to the
past
fortunately Peter Wang my co-founder at
anaconda and the other investors agreed
allowed us to kind of grow and startanim
focus so that we could continue to grow
it and but since about 2014 2015 it's
been pretty independent and been growing
thanks to the work of Leah and her staff
as well as Andy Terrell and the new
board and the old board and all the
people that have gone before our
volunteers we founded in 2012 with Perry
Greenville and farinata Perez and John
hunter and Jared Millman and Anthony
scope hats helped us open the first peg
account over those early days was a lot
of fun you know III there there are
times some people ask me how do you do
this how do you make sure it's gonna
work
you know I don't know there's some times
when I know something is gonna work I
just you just bear just persistent it's
gonna work doesn't matter we'll get
through it yeah there's hiccups there's
problems we'll get through it because
this is gonna work and it's the right
thing it needs to exist see and I don't
have that confidence with everything but
with num focus I did I knew this is the
right thing and partly because the
support of the Fernando the critical
mass of people that were associated with
it and then because of the staff that
worked on it and then the pie today the
pie that we discovered sort of one of
the first things we did with num focus
to discover the PI data was this
untapped energy latent energy anaconda
was the company founded with Peter and
and I it was renamed anaconda and
roughly the same time when it was sort
of control the company is now in the
hands of the board which is led by Lana
Napier who's chairman and then a new CEO
Scott Collison so anaconda as a
different company it's an enterprise
software company a growing company great
services great products check them out
but it's different that's potentially a
good thing
in terms of raising more resources
lessons from gnome focus raising money
from donors is hard most people just
don't give if they aren't getting
something just take of your own behavior
think of my behavior it's you know
you're not money scarce right that's
your representation in the world you
vote with your money all the time it's
hard just to hand that over to somebody
kind of what is this company struggle to
do it - it's a when John Hunter passed
away another example I've had a previous
example with donors trying to fund my
lab when John Hunter passed away in 2012
suddenly it was he just helped us start
an unfocused give a keynote talk at Syfy
contracted colon cancer and passed away
within a month tragic for the community
and his wife left his wife with three
kids so we basically the campaign trying
to raise money for his widow over over
the course of three or four weeks yes
maybe it's three months ultimately most
of it came in early but we ended up
raising about $90,000 that's very nice
the only hand a check to his widow but
it was also a little disappointing I
knew there were millions of matplotlib
users and yet you know and it was very
power law distributed some gave him some
few gave a lot and a few gave what they
could you know and again this isn't to
make you feel guilty but it is to make
you observe that this isn't magic you
know you don't have to raise your hand
but ask you to ask yourself how many you
are sustaining members and I'm focus
right I it's a fairly simple thing to do
monthly donation I'm focus you know five
bucks a month doesn't hurt anybody most
people can do that but who takes the
time to do it but when you do it's
meaningful and it adds up in aggregate
significantly so it's hard but it's
worth it there's always some available
there and you can keep pushing on that
herding cats is hard - also lessons for
Numb focus helped me understand the
challenge of organizing human behavior
at scale as well I actually learned this
a professor if you've never been in a
faculty meeting with a bunch of smart
people you don't and many of you been in
meetings but you have too many smart
people around the room actually less
gets done kind of this odd phenomena of
alignment it's one reason I think it's
it's kind of the human equivalent of
software services software as a service
or service oriented architecture
effectively you have to have some
groups of people with api's tacking to
each other you can't get a group of
people really more than seven there's a
great article actually came out this
summer from Harvard Business Review and
the most productive meetings have fewer
than eight people and that's interesting
because it matches my statement of I
didn't want an unfocused board to have
more than seven and I was pretty adamant
about that now that didn't happen also
showing that I'm focuses at my
organization it's an organization of the
community
I was pretty adamant that I have you
know five to seven people on the board
just for this reason just to allow it to
be efficient in its decision-making and
an action it's really hard you can
definitely maintain standards by
committee but it's really hard to
innovate with a large group so consensus
led development is a myth right
development happens with individuals and
then you sort of organize those
individuals together again I don't
understand all the issues here
definitely understand some of the
problems and it has to do with our
neuroscience and has to do with who we
are as humans and we're still learning
what really happened for an unfocused
and how it became sustainable it was a
bit of a bit of a risk I raised two
point two five million for continuum
from about thirty investors right by
hook or by crook
I'm scattering around grabbing money
from people whoever I can to start this
crazy thing and Peter Wang who is also
my co-founder we agreed that we would be
able to fund um focus for its first year
it's two or three years by Bex basically
paying for administrative development
and you know not knowing where any money
was coming from just taking it from our
investors basically and then we we got
money from investors not because they
like us or because they're there were
they're wanting to donate to the good to
the cause we got it because they they
thought they'd make money back right
that's that's what investors do
investors give you money because they're
gonna make you're gonna make their money
back that means you have to have a
business model means you have to have
something you're selling you have to
figure out how to do that
we were able to actually return 6x
return to those investors in three years
using the you know rob Peter to pay Paul
principle the same way most of us make
money in the stock market today
go you know it's them to sell to the
next guy right at a higher price but of
course those new people are being to pay
the higher higher price because they
believe in the future they believe what
you built and where it's gonna go and so
you know there is a lot of narrative
building for companies nonetheless
didn't have that ability and I'm focus
can't go out and get investors and say
hey come invest
we're gonna actually I think we made a
little change that so stay tuned next
year but for now it's not that's that's
difficult and if and not hard we found
actually that Lindbergh said told us
that the PyCon was basically the way
that PSF got funded and so we let after
that conversation we said well maybe I
did it could be the same
maybe PI data can be the engine that
helps the admin of nun focus stay afloat
so at least it can stay consistent and
we found that was true not initially we
lost a lot of money on PI data initially
but by about 2014 the outworked
and you could basically barely to
survive barely and so that was part of
getting them focus on its foot and on
its feet so we have a couple more
minutes to learn some of the lessons
from continuum days
so at continuum we tried many product
models our goal a continuum as a build a
product company and we didn't know what
to build we know what it would be I had
some ideas array servers numpy in the
cloud and some kind of basic concepts we
sold to investors and some of them
worked out we didn't really understand
we didn't really think of the
distribution model we didn't think of
what became our actual product that was
successful until we got started it's
also a principle of can I got a start
with something here and then pivot and
then listen to the market and move the
direction the market wants you to so we
tried SAS model software's the service
models where Carrie and I kind of cloud
Macari was the very first Jupiter in the
cloud solution and it existed in 2013
right and we paid the price for that
Jupiter wasn't ready for you in the
cloud in 2013 there wasn't this a pre
docker it was pre all these facilities
that make it a lot easier today but we
were innovating trying to make something
happen and a counter cloud and have lots
to say about SAS models if you're
interested any of this I'm happy to talk
with you I'm in fact what I'm doing now
is I'm mentoring people in building
companies I would love to see many many
more companies being built around
open-source I'd love to talk to anybody
who wants to do that like I said I
evaluate entrepreneurs is real and I'd
love to encourage more of them and so
I'd love to help in any of the lessons
I've learned I'd love to help you build
your company if you're so inclined we
had an open core model with numba numba
pro io pro MP optimized we're experiment
with that we did consulting services and
training that's that's really good for a
non VC back business you
they can't do consulting and training
for a VC back business just doesn't work
but it's good for a suits chap or a
startup business where you're not
getting VC funding we did grant open
source research lab we've got grants
from DARPA got money from various
sources that can generate resources
we've finally found the complementary
product model basically it's the product
that you sell when the open source thing
is popular so you have open sourcing is
used and demand for a complementary
product grows and that's kind of a model
that's known to work it's kind of my
favorite software model that supports
open source is sell the complementary
product I still believe those
complementary products have to stay
ahead there's a constant churn because a
lot of the features the component
product ultimately become open source
and so that's there's a bit of
strategizing and work to build the right
one you definitely need venture funding
to scale marketing sales they're
critical to the business gross margins
on a product are great but operating
costs will kill you
initial operating costs will kill you it
takes a little while for the operating
costs to be efficient so the gross
margins on product actually help you
consulting is the opposite the operating
costs are smaller your gross margins are
smaller be operating costs are smaller
too and explaining that to to VCS is
hard so having you know - consulting and
product companies which we had I was
running two businesses for a long time
at AI makanda and actually but not not
differentiating the the financials and
so building a narrative around our
businesses was difficult and the
narrative around your business is
actually essential as a leader of
business your narrative is almost the
most important thing you're doing to
create the concept that's causing people
to think and organize around your work
so allowing the investors to open-source
is hard got to pick the right pesters
pick the right metrics you've got to
bring in outside help you're not gonna
do it alone no matter how brilliant
capable you are it's a team that does it
together and so almost of building a
business around open-source is about
team building and having the right
people on the team it's actually true of
open source projects as well good open
source projects become good because the
team they could they attract not because
of anyone in particular I see a lot of
open source projects with one a really
really great developer that don't grow
as quickly because the team doesn't grow
all right so I realize I'm
at a time got more things to say as you
might imagine I'll give you just a
little brief window what we're doing now
just as kind of learning from the past
organizing for the future quad sights go
to market business is about connecting
companies to communities we're basically
the group that helps organizations
connect with communities and try to
figure out how to how to interface with
them I almost say a lobbying group to
the open source companies kind of have
their cycle and they spin really at this
rate
open-source communities kind of spin at
this rate and then you need someone to
help transform those gears that's what
we do and we help them around the
problem of data science and AI and
machine learning it's built from the
same team that the many of the same
management members that create a
continuum have joined me just spin out
to on site we actually consider anaconda
to be our first spin-out company and
none focus to be our first spin-out a
non-profit right so it's the same group
then we're basically doing this again
but intentionally organizing to build
other companies and spin up other
organizations which our whole goal is to
spit out more and more companies and
have a portfolio of people that we're
helping our core business that quant
site is quant site labs membership
sustainable open source partnerships
custom data science and machine learning
consulting and staffing mentoring and
training we're embracing the concept
that open source is about learning and
growing and teaching and that there's a
big shortage of people in the world who
need that help and that that shortage
isn't fixed by a 12-week course it's
fixed by years of engagement by
apprenticeships and by working together
to train the next generation so we do
consulting AI ml on Big Data Jupiter
everywhere big believers in Jupiter lab
we think a lot of the world can be
replaced by a lot of world software can
be replaced by plugins did you per lab
and then optimizing Python a lot of
pythons out there being deployed in an
in a suboptimal way we can help to make
it better our partnerships is in open
source or interesting I think and
they're just evolving but this is where
we help companies connect with
communities and we help them a couple of
ways we help them prioritize their needs
so we help companies instead of spending
millions of dollars on internal projects
or effectively Forks of open source
don't do that actually take less than
the many are spent internally spend it
on supporting open source so that
there's a share in R&D gets built then
you can build your
pieces on top but with a more
sustainable approach hired from the
community a lot of hiring dollars are
spent recruiting dollars spent that
could be spent on promoting open source
projects and then hiring the people that
join those projects get open source
support we have a support and
maintenance approach that we provide for
the particular set of an umpire
ecosystem and applying lessons of open
source helping people internally do the
things that make open source company
successful we have a webinar we host
this is to help communities project
companies their roadmaps or their wish
lists where they're headed a lot of
communities have things they're doing
the companies don't know about it so the
open source webinar is one part of an
answer to help grow that information
transfer publicize these roadmaps it's
recorded transcribed so you attend the
webinar or you can just watch the
pre-recorded or that or read the
transcript superior of the previous
sessions we have a quant site labs which
is our research and lab basically where
we train people where we work on hard
problems the goal is to higher the
number the PI data core team we'd love
to have the PI data core team at Kron
site Labs or at least a subset of it
improve the connection to numpy of numpy
to ml frameworks GPU support improve the
foundations of array computing super lab
data catalog standards packaging these
are a list of the things we've already
identified as areas we're working on and
will work on more to projects you were a
annex in d you'll hear more about those
become the talk that Saul and I are
giving later today so I won't say more
about that we work on Apache arrow we
work on X and D X and D is a
generalization of numpy to learn more
about that in the talk basically pandas
is - arrow as numpy istex and D for
people that want to know the
relationship that's a pretty high-level
way need to find a Rea interface we'll
talk more about that later
super lab won't really talk much about
this later but if you're not using
Jupiter lab today you should really take
a hard look at it if you're building
basically custom dashboards without
leveraging super lab I would take a hard
look at that and see if you're basically
going in a direction that's going to be
less sustainable than if you're writing
plug-ins - super lab I think there's a
really good software that's gone on here
for the past couple of years a lot of
really good technologies been built
we're big supporters of kind of forge
folks that kind of forge community is
basically a distributed
community of thousands of developers who
create recipes for prepackaged Python
and other modules Julia our there's lots
if you think of he packed with Conda and
so it's a cross-platform packaging
solution we also incubate young
companies like I said my real goal in
kearney quan site is to sponsor lots of
entrepreneurs and so we have you know
innovative approaches to helping
open-source young companies get started
we've already spun out companies before
okay I kind of know some of the some of
the ways Blamey companies are is broad I
don't know all the things but I'm happy
to share what I do know with people that
want to build companies based on
open-source we have a small venture fund
called Quonset initiate we started that
could actually find funding for these
companies as well so we all we already
have you know three young companies
they're incubating inside of our
portfolio we're open to more and open
teams that IO if you want to go check it
out it's very nascent very new not
really ready for you to use daily but
we'd love you to check it out and give
us feedback the intent of open teams is
to be a find collaborators advisers and
help your open source projects grow and
build a network of people around open
source and then build your open source
portfolio showing the availability for
commercial work available for all the
local source projects try it out give us
feedback that's all I'm asking right now
I'm guarantee it's not gonna be not
useful to you I'd be a little useful but
try it out and give us feedback and look
for more in 2019 all right I appreciate
that ago whenever a little bit over time
so maybe you have time just for a couple
of questions if you'd like to go and
take a break I think that's the time is
now but if you have questions I'm happy
to take a couple thank you
[Applause]
and brave souls either that or I
couldn't understand anything I said
which may be likely okay no problem I
can't see if anybody's there we go right
here in the front there's a microphone
here if you can use it also repeat the
question unless you use the microphone
thank you so much first and my question
is as you can see some libraries because
it's open source and it's out of the
market like there no and no one continue
to contribute to those kind of platforms
one of my pipeline is heavily depending
on their know and fortunately and
unfortunately I have to rewrite
everything to tensorflow or something
else
I really wish we can ask someone from
corporate I wish to save us some time to
change your library
we wish it's do you thing is there any
other opportunities to for example for
your company to contribute to some of
the great libraries existing the history
but unfortunately I don't have other
contributors continuously service serve
this kind of library I would love to I
mean that's really the goal of Kansai
labs is we have an active campaign going
out to companies to basically tell them
the story of they've got a time bomb
they got a ticking time bomb if you're
depending on the non Piko system you
have a ticking time bomb you have no
plan for its support because the world
is moving and you know maybe that time
scale is five years maybe it's ten years
but eventually you're gonna need up to
rewrite your code or why instead of that
problem which could be tens of millions
of dollars for every particular company
a little pay a little insurance to fund
a group of people who are maintaining
that code because right now there's
nobody really formally maintaining that
code so Akal on-site labs yes I would
love to hire people I'd love to have a
team of hundred people and I think it's
possible there's certainly we started
that a continuum we saw that we saw
hints that it could work and so we're
just pursuing that actively over the
next year or two to see if we can't
build up a team of 15 20 or 30 people
who are able to spend their time
supporting projects that are used like
the a no the I was a perfect example of
one that really deserves somebody
maintain it and love to do it so that's
the goal
we're out trying to basically raise
money from companies so each together
not any one company has to spend a ton
of money but together they can spend a
little bit and then support the
ecosystem a great question the other
question
hi oh yeah what's your opinion on how
you can kind of coordinate source
efforts to kind of reduce overlapping
and duplicate efforts that's a good
question too how to reduce duplicating
efforts I'm less concerned about initial
duplication than I used to be in the
sense that some duplication is not
completely overlapping I think
information flow is a big one that's one
reason we have the open source
directions webinar I think most people
just don't know about the stuff that's
out there open source gotten so big that
so many people are doing that that's
just now it's now it's like an
information problem I think it's it's
best practices kind of if everybody kind
of realizes you know do a little google
searching before do a little searching
I think indexes on open source projects
could be helpful but ultimately I only
want to prevent duplication that's
that's that's fueled by lack of
information you know if somebody really
feel strongly that their project is
different enough they want to do it okay
that's fine I mean more that's better
because they're they're framings a
little different they're gonna improve
it a little bit better
I just want to enable reuse the other
thing I think we're working on is kind
of interfaces connection connective
tissue you know if you found if you form
foundational structures interfaces then
people can do varying variances varying
degrees of that right now we have kind
of big silos being built without those
interfaces that end up with lots of
duplication where we got to be able to
find some common ground so a lot of
times it's actually taking the existing
duplicated efforts of maybe finding
common ground between them and building
a a sub library all these things just
take time and resources and coordination
but the question is there could be an
umbrella organization that sort of
provides some guidance for that yep
yep so there's lots of even on our own
projects there's a bunch of duplication
yeah I said here's I hear that and I see
that I think you know none focus could
do things like help those orbitals
projects know about each other
I think they think they do I I don't
want to a lot of times what it looks
like duplication isn't right
there's the Venn diagram as a completely
overlap right and so I think none focus
could do is maybe as you see duplicate
of efforts with the right sponsorship
from companies you know put grants to
form intersect take a piece of that and
make a dependency make a dependency
that's shared and so then the
differences can populate but then the
shared code can also populate that's one
approach I think none focus is perfectly
positioned with enough support from
enterprise to do those kind of grants
yeah question um let's get one question
form up here oh great thank you
sorry way in the back came a little late
you may have addressed this but what's
your perspective on how managed services
cloud services and and those type of
changes in the industry affect open
source sinners intersect with it and
especially if somebody's actually tried
it once before yeah
menace services certainly the big
players are starting to dominate right
it's it's and there's there's well-known
examples of big companies sort of just
taking from open source to their managed
services and there's some reactionary
responses of that some people going as
far as trying to create licenses that
avoid it you know I don't if someone
wants to experiment with licenses I'm
not gonna oppose them I think that's
fine I tend to be a little nervous about
that approach because it it creates FUD
for the community fear uncertainty and
doubt
where's what you need is growth I
actually much more much more appreciate
incentivize incentivizing those open
source companies to actually give back
to the open source they're depending on
and just helping them understand the
need that usually once you can do that
effectively it does start to work but it
does take good marketing good
good narrative building good good
relationships to make that happen I
think we're gonna see more of it I think
one thing those companies do that's
affecting us right now is those big
companies then go and actually create
their own open-source projects they've
recognized the power of open source
communities and they go trying to make
their own rather than kind of join with
communities that are there they just
invent their own and grow them and
that's creating some opportunities
certainly there's more software out
there but it's not it's differently
managed I think we'll learn from it I
don't have any you know I think the best
thing to do is keep building business
models that incentivize those big
companies who use open-source to give
back to the open source that's they say
they depend on do we have time for one
more question
yeah I'm okay final question so I'm
coming from an academic sphere actually
in biomedical engineering and I'm just
wondering if you think things have
changed in terms of incentives and ways
that academics can responsibly
contribute and if they haven't changed
much since since you switched over to
the business end or so what can
academics do to be responsible users and
contributors
that's the question strains that's a
great question yeah yeah of course
academia has been they've out the
fountainhead of a lot of open source and
still is right basically rogue academics
and graduate students have been doing
this for a while I think it has changed
to some degree I do I think people are
recognizing there's a lot of there's a
lot more journals to publish the take
open source projects as a as an entry
and so that helps if you get a
publication out of your work then that
helps your traditional career path so I
think it has changed I think there are
good examples you know Fernando Perez
has been on the forefront of this you
just got a full a professorship tenured
professorship at Berkeley effectively
for his contributions to Jupiter so I
think that's that's a big deal that's
that's recognized a lot of folks I think
a bigger deal is also organizations like
kind of South NASA DARPA are recognizing
that they are funding a lot of open
source and need to be funding a lot of
open source they've kind of had a what I
would consider to be a confused
perspective on out of what they're
trying to encourage in the marketplace
and that had a place for open source
really it's kind of you know it's either
it's kind of
dietary or they've sort of stood open
source and then it became okay we don't
really have to do with it and now
there's actually active work going to
--have maybe the things we find not to
be open source and that's happening in
NASA and NSF and other so it's program
managers get out to we're familiar with
ecosystem I think there are the
foundational funding mechanism academia
is changing and that will absolutely
change academic credit value by your
statements so I'm very hopeful actually
these processes just take time because
they're in human timescales so five a
decade right and there's changing it's
getting better so I expect to see
continued to see in the future a lot of
open source come out of academia still
we have a very brief question from up
here okay hi how is open source gonna
change when at least four oh four I
guess with like the growth of two bill
models you need like a lot of data and
trying to find like these datasets and
trying to find these sources to own
collect data you know like there isn't
like a lot of what happened code is
actually data and the data is not
available right likes or yeah and then
like how is open source going to grow
and kind of change when a lot of these
open source kind of libraries to like
build models and stuff you need kind of
more data yeah that's a good question I
think that will be the debate of the
future actually is open data you know
there's some who say that all code will
be speed data they'll be neural nets and
they must be data training a model
that's been trained I don't believe
that's true I think there'll be a large
subset of things that are currently
programs it will just be data and I
think that will be an interesting debate
for the next twenty years you have two
sides of it you do have people that are
promoting open data and there's
incentive to do that a lot of the big
cloud providers actually want to bring
you to their cloud by giving you data so
I think we'll have that movement
happening the same time we'll have
companies have always been protective of
their data they'll keep being protective
of their data and so you'll end up with
this interesting dynamic happening
probably even more so than in software
so I expect we'll have a mixed world
where data is there's a lot of data
that's private but there's a lot of data
that's public and the more data that's
public the more it refines the data
that's private just like open source
code open source code actually causes
companies to be serious about what they
make proprietary they don't just make
every software proprietary they make
only the pieces that really matter and I
think we'll see the same in data most
data will become available governments
will make it available there's a lot of
folks are incentivized to make it free
and then there'll be a shrinking of the
data that's proprietary but we'll always
have both pinks are the questions I
really appreciate it thanks for let me
join you
[Applause]